The Huffington Post published an article
in 2015 titled no white people will
never understand the black experience
the writer reasons that a white person
no matter how blind to color can only
understand so much of something they
cannot viscerally experience to her
though white people must still educate
themselves on schematic racism to help
actively fight against something they
cannot truly understand in the movie
menace to society the Hughes brothers
are on this exact mission educating
white people we made that movie for
white people we made the film to inform
them of something they didn't know in
this video I want to explore how movies
teach prejudice using various engaging
cinematic techniques menace to society
attempts to do what the Huffington Post
says is impossible the movie tries to
give an outsider a window into what it's
like to grow up in a poor black
neighborhood and in doing so they teach
Outsiders to empathize with people in
that situation the movie accomplishes
this from the start in the first two
moments the rioting scene and the
convenience store robbery the rioting
footage purposefully gives a distorted
perspective of poor black people from
the opening shot the camera looks at the
carnage of the Watts Riots safely from a
helicopter like someone would see live
news footage on TV the camera is
physically above the violence and
looking down on the people rioting once
we get to ride footage on the ground the
filming is from the perspective of the
riot police never the black people the
white news commentator in the background
puts obvious emphasis on the cops
instead of the rioters
[Music]
even the pixelation of fact makes all
the black people look the same removing
their face from a story this allows the
viewer to easily generalize them as a
group not as individuals the Hughes
brothers are cleverly capturing the
black experience in a stereotypical way
and in a way many white people
experience black communities from a
distance and mostly with stereotypes
they further reinforce white stereotypes
of black people by showing the main
characters later robbing a convenience
store
another stereotypical black behavior
they establish this white bias so they
can spend the rest of the movie
deconstructing it after the riot footage
we go from a white commentator to a
black narrator and we no longer see the
black people from a distance we enter
their homes and live within their
personal stories that was the first time
I'd ever seen my father kill anybody but
it wasn't the last a guy used to it
though to complement this intimacy the
violence in the film becomes much
grittier than the far removed violence
we normally see in news footage from a
helicopter the cinematography becomes
clear colorful and up-close this change
was done intentionally by the Hughes
brothers to show that violence is not
like what we see on TV if it pops off
make it pop off quick and make the
aftermath ugly not like Rambo where guys
just go down and that's it growing up
most violence just looked goofy and
unorthodox people had twigs in their
eyeballs and shit
it wasn't pretty by first using various
techniques establishing the black
community as faceless violent rioters
the rapid cinematic change of the black
community into up-close relatable and
vulnerable characters deconstructs the
racial stereotypes start with the poor
black population as an outsider sees
them then bring the outsider in and
challenge their initial perspective with
a personal story of loss and excessive
violence capture the racism and then
deconstruct getting white people on the
inside of poor black neighborhoods is a
great strategy to helping them
understand the cycle of poverty I
remember when pitching the movie to
newline they go well what is different
between this and when we see the black
guy on the news every morning running
from the helicopter I go well you're in
the helicopter and you don't know why
that kid is running Ashlee films have
used bias cinematic techniques to
highlight sexism as well as racism this
is done more subtly but just as
powerfully in the Silence of the land's
the main character arc in the movie is
Clarice Starling overcoming the mental
trauma of her childhood but there's also
the backdrop of her struggling to
distinguish herself in an almost all
male profession men's
actualized clarice throughout the movie
whether it's subtly checking her out or
outright asking her on a date we see her
isolation most powerfully in subjective
point of view shots throughout the movie
where we see through the eyes of furries
all the towering male figures looking
down on her
these cinematic choices put us in the
perspective of the victim even the final
scene has a man staring her down with
her unable to see him echoing the men in
her career always watching her and
looking down on her the underlying idea
here is that even subjective experiences
like growing up in a poor black
neighborhood or being a woman in a
male-dominated profession will always be
impossible to experience as an outsider
but directors use subjective filmmaking
techniques to try to recreate it and
sometimes they do a pretty good job of
course they don't always get it right it
seems like historically mainstream
American cinema has had trouble
capturing authentic aspects of the Asian
experience up until very recently Asian
characters were almost always either the
sensei who teaches using his
Americanized Eastern wisdom or a racist
punchline maybe the most important idea
to grasp in these discussions of
creating film bias is that the extent
outside of fictional storytelling in a
famous example how is it possible that
the police officers who physically
assaulted Rodney King were acquitted
there are many ways to approach this
question and the racial and political
reasons for their acquittal are
undeniable but another reason is
necessary to understanding that trial
and it's how the lawyers defending the
Los Angeles Police Department distorted
the video footage of the beatings to
suit their story the defense attorneys
broke the video down into stills
freezing the frames so that the gesture
the raised hand is torn from its
temporal place in the visual narrative
the video is not only violently
decontextualized but violently
recontextualized
it is played without a simultaneous
soundtrack which had it existed would
have been littered with racial and
sexual slurs against Rodney King the
lawyers whitewashed the footage for
their own narrative this is a perfect
example of racially biased filmmaking
used for evil the lawyers create a
narrative that white people are used to
experiencing and this deceit tries to
justify the obviously unjust beating of
Rodney King using buys filmmaking to
create a distorted narrative is still
happening by the way if you ever want to
test this see how two different media
outlets film the same event if your
network supports Betsy DeVos her Senate
hearing his films like this if not its
films like this The Huffington Post
article maybe right white people can
never truly understand the black
experience and this also applies to men
who never truly understand what it's
like to be a woman in a
dominated field but the closest we can
get maybe through a close reading of
commentary on the black experience like
in menace to society or by the
perspectives and camera choices like
into the Silence of the lands each movie
uses the power of cinematography to show
experiences outside of our own race or
gender and that's the beauty of movies
we get sucked into lives and experiences
we could never possibly experience
ourselves and some directors use that
ability to teach us something about the
world around us when these choices are
used for good we learn about the human
experience but when they're used for bad
they cloud the truth and present the
world in a narrow-minded and dangerous
way so keep a lookout thanks for
watching
[Music]